There's a cool little video on the,
on YouTube.
Let me just show that now and
it explains how this works.
I'm actually going to cut out
the section when it starts talking about
rabbits, but that's because you guys
already understand how stereo works.
>> Microsoft's Kinect has a depth censor
that can tell how far away things are.
In this stream, brighter colors are
closer and darker ones are farther away.
This video will explain how it does
this which is pretty clever and
not how many people
initially thought it worked.
>> By the way, these things
are relatively easy to implement.
You can implement these things too.
Just hook up your Kinect.
You can use, just write a little
program, or even Matlab.
You can do it directly and display it.
And it's kind of cool
to experiment with.
The thing that I like about this
video that you can see well is, he,
he sets it up so you can look at this in
a dark room using a IR-sensitive camera,
which, by the way,
most digital cameras are IR sensitive.
So if you do this, you probably look
at this on the video feed coming off of
your digital camera while you've
illuminated things with the Kinect and
you'll see it.
Now if you take a night
vision camera and
look at the projection from the kinect,
you won't see a grid of numbers, but
rather a random speckle pattern.
This accomplishes the same goal, though,
because no group of specks looks like
any other, so the Kinect automatically
knows the angle of every group and
can therefore triangulate
distances just like shown before.
The downside of this technology is
that it can only work indoors because
sunlight would wash out
the speckle pattern, and
similarly, multiple Kinects
would confuse each other.